foreign
let's go out to Candace in Richmond
Virginia Candace welcome to the show
hi thank you
um my question is I am almost 60 000 in
debt and I am not sure where to go from
here
you call the right place okay so tell us
about this debt what's made up of the
60k
um so this was pretty big Ramsey stuff
um but I have a key lock
um I have a personal loan which was for
taxes
um because I ended up owing taxes uh my
car I have a credit card at 401k loan
um and then my phones
and then there's a little bit of um
uh medical debt as well I think you've
collected them all
yeah we're running out of types of debt
you could even go get okay right so
what is your household income right now
um it is just under seventy thousand
okay is it just you
yes okay
cool so what are your next steps well
tell me about this what do you have
right now in the bank or things that you
could sell
um well I I do have my thousand dollar
emergency fund
um and as far as things I can sell I've
already filled some tools out of my
garage and I'm going through the rooms
in my house I'm trying to declutter so
that I can sell stuff and get it out
awesome so we're already on the right
track and what do you do for work
um I do arbitration for an insurance
company okay are you able to take on a
side hustle or two
um I've been thinking about it I am a
single mom so my time is limited on what
I can do but um yes well that's
impressive you're already crushing it is
this uh she in daycare are he in daycare
um one is in school and one is in
daycare okay
but you're willing to do something even
if it's part time to try to create a
little more income because I'm looking
at the numbers here I'm going all right
60k in debt making 70 how much can we
throw at this debt you know 20 30k if
we're lucky right that gets it done in
two or three years
right that's what we're looking at now
so I'm going how do we speed this thing
up as we start putting these into our
debt snowball smallest to largest let's
start attacking it but right now we just
need a bigger shovel compared to the
hole
right do you have uh any support or help
with your kids
um no it's all by yourself
what do you do for a living
um I work for an insurance company okay
right currently I'm working from home
but we are going back a couple of days a
week starting next month what is that
going to do to your internal budget it's
going to cost you more in child care
um it's not going to cost any more in
child care but it's going to cost me a
lot more in gas because I live about an
hour and a half from the building oh
okay
um and that was my bigger question
is this what you want to do long term is
there opportunities for you to begin to
at least throw some lines in the water
and see if there's not another 80 or 90
or 100 000 job out there instead of the
70 000 job that may even be closer to
you that may may allow you to stay
continue working from home if that works
for you
um but anytime I feel I just really
don't like the either or scenario and I
always at least want to try and see if
there's a third or fourth or fifth
option out there that I don't know about
the other thing I want to tell you how
old are your kids
and three six and three okay
um have you been through it personally
over the last five six years
oh yes yeah
I'm sorry I hate that for you
um sometimes the Temptation in those
moments is to
pour every remaining ounce we have into
those kids as some sort of
protective prophylactic like a way to
try to insulate them from the hurt that
has been going on and it might still be
continuing to some degree inside that
house is that fair
yes I want to tell you the other side of
that
when you don't owe anybody any money and
mama is financially safe
there's a piece that courses through
that house it's the air that gets pumped
into that home that is restorative in a
way that you can only dream about right
now on this side of owing sixty thousand
dollars
I tell you that to tell you if there's
no way if there's a way
that you can secure
thirty thousand bucks in a side hustle
fifteen thousand dollars into side
hustle
um and it's going to cost you a little
bit more in this or a little bit more in
that and it's going to cost you the most
expensive thing which is tying with
these little ones if you can do that for
a small amount of time
you do that for six months you do that
for a year you do that for 18 months the
back end
of having a home that is
anxiety free a home that is peaceful
um for those little little baby's
nervous system
um for your nervous system it's just
such a gift
and so I know the Temptation is to say
yeah but I've got these moments are so
precious and God they are but man whole
peaceful moments on the back end are
they're just worth their weight in gold
right so if you can find it go for it
I I'm not opposed to another job no I
know you're not I don't like change yeah
I know I know you've been through enough
for the last few years
and and I've been with my job for 17
years but um I I do want to get out I
don't want to do this I don't like the
direction they're going
um I've never needed a resume I don't
even know how to do a resume well we got
you so here's what I want you to do I
want you to stay on the line we're gonna
I'm gonna send you a couple of things
I'm gonna um send you uh we're gonna
send you a link to Ken Coleman's Resume
Builder it's going to walk you through
there's a bunch of resume templates
there and I'm going to send you his um
get clear assessment that says okay I've
got this skill set I've been doing this
job for this long what are some other
things I might be interested in what are
some other things that might be
instantly qualified for what are some
things that I'm really close and I just
need to go get some more education get
some more schooling and I'm right there
um so I'm going to send you that and
we're going to send you his book
proximity principle which is this simple
way of getting connected with people in
your local community who may be doing
the job that you want to be doing and
how do I reach out and make that thing
happen is that cool okay yeah so hang on
the line here we're gonna get you taken
care of I love it and Candace what is
the car worth versus what you owe
um I owe
those
um my car payments 170 4.96 a month okay
I might consider if you sold that thing
you'd have 10 grand to go buy yourself a
nice cash car that could get you from A
to B just fine while you get out of this
debt and it might help you see the light
at the end of this tunnel
if you can clear 10 of your debt next
week it will give you a little bit of
Hope and I think that's what you need
right now is a little bit of proof that
this stuff actually can work that you
can get out of this and then start doing
the math going all right if I'm going to
try to get rid of this debt in two years
that's you know 25 or 30k a year that's
2500 bucks a month how do I make up that
much margin through spending less and
making more and that will help you stay
on target so you're not just hoping and
wishing instead you go I'm going to be
debt free two years from now no matter
what come hell or high water I'm gonna
be there
and on top of all that stuff we just
gave you I'm gonna gift you one year of
Financial Peace University and one year
of every dollar premium
so that you can start to map out that
plan map out your income get encouraged
by the videos you can join a virtual
class online do that you need a game you
need a gang to walk with you're doing
this alone right now and you don't have
to there's millions of people who are on
the same Journey who can encourage you
who can get you connected to other
places and give you some ideas that's
what this is all about so hang online
we're about to send you a whole bunch of
stuff and I hope it gives you a little
bit of Hope pun intended so thank you so
much for the call Candace we are
cheering you on